so one of the things that I like to do
is try to believe in the people around
me right it's it's my one word it's what
I stand for and I try to apply that to
all the people who are on my team as
well and often that's hopefully it's
always to their benefit and usually to
my benefit as well but sometimes it
doesn't work out sometimes you know you
bring people on your team and it's just
not the right fit their career path
doesn't match what you can offer them I
have pretty low turnover on my team and
I like to think it's because they're not
you know my team is not just able to
exercise their skills but they also like
the work that we're doing they like the
impact that we're having but one former
employee that comes to mind his name was
Kevin who worked for me for a year or
two years and he was doing a good job I
just felt like he could do more with his
life that after talking to him multiple
times what he wanted to do just didn't
match up with what I could provide you
know I like being flexible I like trying
to incorporate my team's passions into
the work that they're doing and being
creative and open but sometimes it can't
sometimes somebody just wants to do
something totally outside and totally
different and in that situation the best
thing for him to do was to leave the
work that he was doing with me and go
find another opportunity and what was
really humbling and what was really
warming for me was he recently made a
video talking about his experience with
me and the time that we spent and this
was I don't know five six seven years
ago I don't remember and he still
considers a time that he spent with me
to be one of the best in his
professional career and the mentorship
and the learning and the less that I
learned from that was always trying to
make sure that the people that are on my
team and the people that are around me
I'm trying to pull the best out of them
even if in the long term they're not
meant to be good fits with me and
hopefully people who have left your
organization still feel like you treated
them fairly still feel like you gave
them opportunities to grow it just
wasn't a fit for where they want to go
and where you want to go and hopefully I
don't think I've had anybody leave who
is on really bad terms with what we're
doing so one two should I clip the Kevin
made and hopefully that inspires you and
how you're doing with people your team
your friends your family you know people
at Walmart everywhere that you can leave
a lasting and positive
oppression on everybody that you weren't
across in your life hi my name is Kevin
Lee and I'm currently the lead advisor
for the J company program thread
sponsored by M bridge in my lifetime
kind of number of advisers and mentors
influenced me but none greater than my
former boss Andrew Carmichael evan is
the an entrepreneur founder in chemical
ecology above and also former board
member and a three nine years I've
worked for evidences marketing manager I
learned many things including how to
offer value first in order creating
meaningful relationships how to earn
money before spending it and of course
how to become confident and almost in
your social setting Bob Holly said the
most important lesson having ever taught
me was how to dream near the end of my
contract with Evan he actually chose not
to renew it because he realized that I
was actually becoming happy and
complacent and he always wanted me
instead to challenge myself become a
better version of it to work hard to
read more to come up perfectionist and
that's because the field would become
profitable for not I'm eternally
grateful because it allowed me to go out
see my true passion to do everything so
thank you
so think again so much for watching I
love to know what you thought of Kevin's
clip I'd love to know you thought about
this topic in general and how you are
treating people and if you're doing a
good enough job across all the people in
your life and having a meaningful impact
even if they meet you for you know 30
seconds or 30 minutes or an hour or one
day how can you have a meaningful
lasting impact on their lives that is
positive and memorable
so I loved if you guys could share an
example of the last person that you have
either impacted in a positive way or
something that somebody had a positive
impact on you even if it's a really
minor thing like somebody left a really
positive comment on your YouTube channel
maybe took five seconds to write but it
made you feel really good just showing
even some of those small little acts of
kindness and gratitude that made you
feel like you came alive sharing those I
think would give people some context and
also hopefully like a list of potential
to do is to show that and pay it forward
to other people as well so leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion and finally I want to give a
shout out to Levi castle as well Levi
thank you so much for ordering my book
it really means a lot to me those you
watching if you want to change at a
shadow
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and also email in your
receipt so that we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon